说说我人生的第一个困境是怎么走出来的
我发现很多人都有这个问题
上周六啊
我们社群还有人问你说胡锡哥
我特别不喜欢现在的工作
感觉每天做过事情没有意义
你没有那群理别各种内耗
万一耗的事情都达出
但是我总出来
请问怎么办
我记得我刚中间毕业的时候
有分配到一家国企
就起到不下面下次的一家单位
干嘛呢
很多大人因为这是不好实际
就是给领导当同学
什么同学呢
就是断查到复松报之
插缩字幕的第一
交活啊
我肯定不喜欢的工作呀
我第一个月就帮我们的导活的角色
当然我们流到脾气比较好
有干这个事情
但是
你确实不是你喜欢的就各种辣车呀
怎么办呀
对吧
有一句话就二分长
有什么二分长呢就是有一些事是你能控制的
有一些事是你不能控制的
就是外部还用你能改变吗
你改变不了你控制不了
反正就怎么用你也控制不了
你怎么办
你只能改变自己能改变的
就是提升自己的能力吗
让我不然让你的能力去批配当成的管理
要不然让你的能力批配的另外一部分管理对吧
所以我当然是想
我需要什么东西呢
好了选什么东西就选了
跟成就坐往这儿
那个时候就八年九九年
被你的思考一样
那时候温泥我爸
那是后白的事了对吧
我们当时单位比较好的一个部门有两台机器
装着这儿温泥我
甚至所有机器都是到此装的大部权
都是这么熊了
我当时决定就坐往叶
但是当时不像现在的个网这么达
你去网上啥什么都知道
现在看变个网站
网页多种力量
那个时候很麻烦的
有找不到材料
你华钱就没进去学习
好在呢
就是我当时单位就是大手
和北霸手很确
有狼狼下面的一个现金是
到北京的话就两百二十
到北达的话就三小时
就每周五的时候
然后我就做错
挂挂挂挂挂挂挂挂
那个时候
中官村啊
没有什么大脑
全是平坦
就一下说就认上一份
就要发票吧
就看不好票
想要做的那个酒店
你们一推门就是一个消息门特便宜
周复的时候是注门
周六周日就开始光
两个上去就是学校状态
突出案光
然后10遍光
就找我能找到的各种感觉说
哪一推出过来
然后工作是乐晚人的时候
没人的时候没什么事的时候
开始不用公司的这个网站
没有人让你变成
就自己想做
你同时朋友都做
然后不会做怎么办就硬抗硬碧
有时候就真的是写不上
把男的那个酒替作子
然后再过上一个认识
到北京还在买书
我许我那个时候工作差不多都是买书用
好呢
最后还真就是把我们公司的网站给
给做出来的
那个时候不要说国旗网站
就很多四零几也都没有网站
只有闹到我们的领导上来的网站
看了这个
多坏了
我来我们的很多下手单位的分佈一次的一些
这个网站
都是我要去做的
包括的话你不是一个原因
包括我们修打影机
然后什么四零几
更好换了都是我修
反而那个时候换了我就修
反而你你换了
对吧
修好了修好了
修好了
你这早在找到这个场价面对吧
但是让你秘密修了
被我读一些小麻布人
多弄修好
这个人比较相提
包括我们领导也看了眼里的话
就给我掉完了工作
看了做什么神组是
领导做我们党
网站的维护
就不干一下那些
什么打头被生动活了
就是开始顺常做一些自己洗完做的事
答案里面说这是你们领导上去
领导不上身体的
那我们领导还是很上手
我说的后来是
很多时候知道我后来辞职了
怎么辞职人呢
我当时的话就是有很多
设许
其实这个网顶也里面有认他
你们知道吗
那个时候能上网的人
都觉得自己很骄傲
就认识了好多人就浪货
本地就我一顿团
有些小
不认识什么
大的企业主
包括河北的很多小企业主
那说会变成这样的
这霸然那些小公司
霸然那边会变成这样
习惑电脑
整个的安静
都是免费的
答案有些时候人就给你点点
给你点钱
后来就是帮个音乐来越多了
然后人家就会给你点钱
就是没多少钱
但是我后来算了算
就是跟我出来的生活费了
所以后来我才敢似直到北达通行的
答案的话大家都知道我的
第一家公司是
是左边成的
对吧
所以给我怎么走的本行
我当你不喜欢你现在的工作时候
说明你现在能力和公司这个环境不批配
可能不是你喜欢不是你三成
怎么办
万些环境你赶不聊
你不用去抱怨
你当然这个一点就没用
改变你自己的能力
提出自己的能力
让你能力和当前的环境批配
或者和外部的环境批配
提出能力
然后就能力去帮助干部的人
让更多能看到
但有越来越来越来越
愿意为你资赐一点点
手域的时候
而这些手域
够你能够生存的时候
你就做饭了
而如果你能把这个事情
做出一个完整的必换出来
其实就是你创业的开始